Tu cries , tu perds !
Le nouveau challenge pété inventé par Squeezie
Aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu d'horreur ou plusieurs, ça dépend de la durée de ces derniers.
Y aura donc des screamers.
Des petits monstres qui font pas plaisir.
Et vous allez devoir fermez vos p*tains de gueules , et ne pas crier.
Et si tu cris, tu quitte la vidéo.
Et tu clique sur une autre vidéo à moi quand même, sinon je me fais un peu baiser dans l'histoire..
Bon
Eh le mec qui veut s'en tirer mais qui assume pas trop les conséquences
Premier Jeu
* musique flippante *
Ok on se réveille à terre au milieu d'une forêt , c'est parfait, situation qui arrive régulièrement bien sûr à tous les français.
Oh le téléphone qui a pris cher.
Je dois trouver de l'aide.
Aller on va trouver de l'aide , on va trouver de l'aide t'inquiete pas.
Déjà j'aimerais trouver une lumière avant de trouver de l'aide
Mais attends, comment je sais où je dois aller la map elle est immense mec.
Mais attends comment je sais où je dois aller la map elle est immense mec.
Ça n'a pas de sens
Là-bas y a un truc là.
C'est quoi ça ?
Est ce qu'on a trouvé une light ?
La réponse est oui bien évidemment.
C'est mieux , c'est une allumette.
C'est quoi ce bras ? Elle a une maladie cette personne.
Même mon propre bras n'est pas aussi fin mec c'est spectaculaire
Est ce qu'on peux allumer une allumette ?
Ok .
J'ai pas crié, j'ai pas crié. J'ai pas crié, j'ai pas crié !
Ok.
Ah d'accord donc on pouvait avoir de l'aide juste ici.
Et au lieu de ça on doit retourner dans cette forêt humide et moite
Bon bah mec
Et si on suivait les rails.
On va suivre les rails mec
Toujours une bonne technique ça, suivre les rails.
Hey par contre non, vous allez pas criez quand le pont s'est pété ?!
Non ! Mais nan , mais nan vous allez rester , vous allez réussir ce challenge vous en faites pas
Vous allez rester sur cette chaîne, ne vous en faites pas.
On va tous réussir ce challenge
Oh là-bas y a de la lumière , on va y aller
On va y aller sans plus tarder.
Et pourquoi il y a une musique qui stresse et qui est en train de monter ?! Tu sais.
Mais pourquoi y a une musique qui stress et qui est en train de monter t'sais.
Oh putain y a une caverne j'avais pas vu.
Oh sa mère.
Oh, la musique s'arrête quand on rentre dans la caverne
Oh, la musique s'arrête quand on rentre dans la caverne-
Et il est pas dégueu le jeu.
Allo
Est ce qu'il y a quelqun eventuellement dans cette caverne.
Arrête , arrête , arrête , arrête , arrête.
Peut pas avoir une meuf qui sort de l'eau là comme dans THE RING là. Avec son puit de m*rde là,
avec son puit de merde là
arrêtez, arrêtez.
Tout ce qui est eau , on oublie s'il vous plaît
Tout ce qui est eau, on oublie s'il vous plaît.
Mec je l'ai..
Mec, je les co-AHHH !!!
AAAAH !
J'ai perdu, allez salut
Salut, allez à bientôt
Ah ahh !
*Rire nerveux et pas assumé*
Ahh pardon !
Ah pardon...
EEh ok
Nouvelle règle, on a trois vies chacun.
Nouvelle règle , on a trois vies chacun
Ouais j'fais partie de ce genre de personne qui invente des règles pendant le jeu.
Bon on y va
BON!
On y va !
C'est bel et bien un petit enfant nu comme dans les films asiatiques qui sort de l'eau.
On connais bien ce ptit enfant nu
Il est très énervant
* Le regard de la souffrance *
J'ai pas crié !
J'ai pas crié ! J'ai pas crié!
Oooh mec
AAAAH MEC !
Elle est à loilpé avec son sac à dos
Heu avec son-...elle est à walpé avec son sac à dos!
Très..
Trè-...
Elle m'a mordue ?!
elle m'a mordue !
Mais dit donc !
Tu fais ce que tu veux avec ton corps, si tu veux te balader à poil avec un sac à dos  y a pas de soucis
Par contre tu évites de me MORDRE s'te plait !
Par contre tu évite de me mordre s'il te plaît
C'est scandaleux !
C'est scandaleux
*Voix étranges qui viennent des arbres*
C'est des arbres , des arbres vivants
J'peux regarder ?
ELLE A MORDUE L'ARBRE !
*Encore traumatisé par l'huldre*
*rire*
Comment oses-tu ?
Comment oses-tu
Pardon là je trouves que ça va un peu trop loin son délire.
Par contre là j'trouve que ça va un peu trop loin son délire
C'est à dire: tu me mords y a pas d'soucis ok.
C'est à dire tu me mords y a pas d'soucis ok , au pire ok
Au pire ok...
Tu mords un arbre !
Tu mords la nature
Je vais appeler une association, ils vont te tomber dessus directs
J'vais appeller une association et y vont te tomber dessus direct
Déjà, pourquoi cet arbre parle ?
Déjà pourquoi cet arbre parle ?
Pourquoi, est ce que , est ce que , peut être à la fin , on fini en arbre
On devient un arbre.
On deviens un arbre
C'est, c'est pas mal
C'est pas mal !
Sachant qu'un arbre, ça vieillit milles fois plus longtemps que nous.
Sachant qu'un arbre sa vie mille fois plus longtemps que nous
C'est pas mal !
c'est pas mal
Très bon scé-...
Très bon..
* Le retour des voix*
Ne...
Ne blesse pas ma mère.
Ne, ne blesse pas ma mère
Mais vasi ,mais arrêtez , arrêtez avec vos délires.
Non mais vas-y arrêtez...
Arrêtez avec vos délires là...
P*tain d'arbre
Putain d'arbres...
Salut
Salut !
Oh il a fait ses courses
Oh il a fait ses courses !
Il a fait ses courses
Il a fait ses courses!
*rire*
Il revient de Lidl, tranquillement. L'arbre il a acheté de la coco, de la noix de coco.
Il reviens de lidl tranquillement
L'arbre il a acheté de la coco
De la noix de coco
* Cris *
Ah merde j'ai mis feu à son truc
Désolé mais, mais c'était le chemin en fait
Désolé, mais c'était...
C'était le chemin en faites !
C'était pour que je puisse passer
C'était pour que je puisses passer...
*Malaise.*
Chuis désolé si je t'ai brulée.
* Double malaise.*
Je suis désolé  si j'tai brulé
Attention screamer
Attention Screamer. Préparez-vous, préparez vous.
Préparez-vous au Screamer.
Préparez vous , préparez vous
préparez vous au screamer
Ne criez pas
Ne criez pas, ne criez pas.
J'aimerai que vous soyez encore là, à la fin de cette vidéo.
Ne criez pas
J'aimerais que vous soyez encore là à la fin de cette vidéo
Parce que tout seul j'assumerai JAMAIS !
Parce que tout seul j'assumerais jamais
Ooh c'est synchro avec l'allumette dans le jeu
OH! Synchro avec l'allumette dans le jeu !
Mais c'est quoi ça ?!
Heu attend, c'est la meuf qui était dans l'arbre. Maintenant elle a prit possession des lumières.
Mais attends c'est la meuf qui était dans l'arbre
Maintenant elle a pris possession de la lumière c'est ça qui se passe
C'est ça qui se passe ?
ÉNORME!
Je vais ouvrir un cinéma 4D, ça y'est.
énorme je vais ouvrir un cinéma 4D ça y'est nouvelle carrière pour Lucas Hauchard c'est parti
Nou-nouvelle carrière pour Lucas Hauchard, c'est parti.
De retour dans la forêt
De retour dans la forêt !
Ah d'accord
Ah d'accord.
On part sur des bruits de...d'ogres.
On part sur des bruits de , d'ogre
Y'a Shrek qui n'est pas loin mec !
Y a un chat qui est pas loin mec
On va aller chanter avec lui
On va aller chanter avec lui.
*chante*
♬♪ told me the world is gonna roll me- ♪♬
♪♬ heuuu-OK! ♬ ♪
*se souvient plus alors le malaise revient *
euh ok
Mec chanter un petit peu comme ça avec vous
Mec, chantez un petit peu comme ça avec vous.
Un petit instant, comme ça, entre nous.
Un ptit instant comme ça entre nous
On a oublié, le contexte,
On a oublié, les bruits de pas,
Et le monstre qui fait...
On a oublié le contexte , on a oublié les bruits de pas et le monstre qui fait
Dix-huit mètres devant moi.
18 mètres devant moi
Tout ça on a oublié
Tout ça on a oublié.
* Oui, il l'avait bien oublié.*
*bruit de pas*
* Grognements *
Damn it...
* Et il le regrette beaucoup.*
*rire*
Il est ignoble
Il est ignoble!
Oh!
Mais c'est bon on est là ! On est devant la maison.
Wooh mais c'est bon on est là
On est devant la maison
Oh mon dieu on a fait tout le tour
On mon dieu, on a fait tout le tour.
Allez on va toquer
Aller on va toquer. Déjà pour avoir une maison ici c'est probablement :
Déjà pour avoir une maison ici , c'est probablement l'ogre
L'OGRE, qui vit là tout simplement.
qui vit là tout simplement
Y'a des lettres, un peu pixelisées.
Ah l'imprimante du mec n'était clairement pas au point.
Il y a des lettres un peu pixélisées
Ah l'imprimante du mec était clairement pas au point
Ah d'accord je peux entrer comme ça !
Ah d'accord , j'peux rentrer comme ça
Ah d'accord toi tu vas chercher de l'aide, c'est...tu braques les gens quoi.
Ah d'accord tu va chercher de l'aide c'est tu braques les gens quoi
C'est quoi ces bruits
C'est quoi ces bruits ?...
Attend y' a un élevage de cochon dans cette maison ou quoi ?
Attends y a un élévage de cochons dans cette pièce ou quoi ?
* Cris *
* Cris, bruits de coups, grognements *
Est-ce que, il vient de tuer tout l'monde?
est ce que il vient de tuer tout le monde ?
Oui.
Oui!
*souffle*
Par là il y a plus de rails par terre.
Ché plus quel chemin suivre je suis perdu.
Par contre là y a plus de rails par terre , j'sais plus quel chemin suivre , je suis perdu
Ah !
Ok c'est là-bas.
Ah , ok c'est là-bas
C'est là-bas
C'est là-bas. Oh putain...
Oh p*tain il l'a l'air d'avoir mal
Oh il a l'air d'avoir mal.
♪  Mais où es-tu ?~ ♪
Mais où es-tuuuu, je suis seul sous la pluiiiiiie
♪ Je suis seul sous la pluie. ~ ♪
DAMN IT !
DAMIT *cri*
WHAAAOU!
Nan j'ai pas crié, j'ai pas crié, ça c'était une manière de s'exclamer
Ça c'était une manière de s'exclamer. C'était pas un cri.
C'était pas un cri
C'était une manière un peu...
C'est juste une manière un peu , un peu commune de dire : oh lala je suis surpris
Un peu commune, de dire...
" Oh la la, je suis surpris."
En faite sa voulait dire : oh lala je suis surpris mais c'était un raccourci en vidéo c'est plus simple
En faites ça voulait dire: " Oh la la j'étais surpris, mais c'était un raccourci en vidéo, c'est plus simple."
Alors-
Alors..
...
Aah !
AAAAH!!!
Et bam !
Oh mon dieu!
Oh mon dieu !
La sorcière du lac nous a sauvé
La sorcière du lac nous a sauvé.
Merci d'avoir joué !
"MERCI D'AVOIR JOUÉ."
Woow !
Whouuu! Sympa ce jeu là ! Ce p'tit jeu d'horreur gratuit.
Sympa ce jeu là, ce p'tit jeu d'horreur gratuit
J'ai apprécié tout ce qui s'est passé durant ce jeu.
J'ai apprécié tout ce qui s'est passé durant ce jeu
Surtout que j'ai pas crié, aucune fois..
Surtout que j'ai pas crié. Aucune fois, donc ça me fait plaisir.
* Hmhm. *
Donc ça fait plaisir..
Quoi ? QUOI ?
Quoi ?
Alors petit replay sur cette séquence parce que vous avez mal vu
wow !
wow je ne crie pas
Voilà les preuves sont là je suis désolé , mais vous êtes encore là vous n'avez toujours pas perdu et bah les ami(e)s sa tombe bien , deuxième jeu d'horreur !
deuxieme jeu
Nous sommes maintenant sur contemp est ce..
Est ce que vous êtes contents ?
Déjà d'être..
Si vous avez crié , parce que cette blague était hyper nulle, vous êtes pardonnés c'est pas grave on va pas compter ça comme une défaite pour le challenge
Ok faut qu'on aille dans cette maison , c'est terrible je déteste, je déteste quand ça se passe dans une p*tain de maison
Entre quatre murs , t'es bien comme un caca quand y a un problème
C'est terrible !
Ok on part dans la grange
Oh y a bien les outils pour tuer des gens , c'est vraiment..
Oh bah y a la clé
Nickel.
Alors!
Bonjour !
J'mappelle euh titouan pratique l'urbex
Je suis pas du tout mal attentioné
Esprit , esprit manifeste toi si tu es là.
Hann!
Mec , même le grand jd n'assumerait pas ce lieu
Vraiment
Y a un truc à faire ou pas ?
vous pensez..
* Grincement très léger *
J'ai eu..
J'ai fai..J'ai vraiment
Oh p*tain j'ai des frissons pour  compenser
J'ai faillis crier sur le craquement de parquet mon gars
Bon faut aller à l'étage, comme d'hab, de toute façon il faut toujours aller à l'étage
et quand t'es à l'étage y a un mec
d'un coup il est au rez-de-chaussée et il te suit à l'étage
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire..
Ok.
Nouvelle salle de bain
Très peu entretenue on a vu quand même un insecte passer
Bon vasi on va aller à l'étage, j'ai compris mec
Aaah
dammit J'ai plus de lampe torche !
Allo !
WTF happend
Déjà prangenroom c'est plus drôle.
Et ça fait même plus de clique.
Donc déjà tu devrais pas faire ça
Oh y a re la lumière
On est content
Ok  on peut ouvrir cette porte maintenant,  qui était fermée , c'est très bien
Alors qu'est ce qu'il y a à la télé
C'est quoi c'est midi ? c'est l'heure de midi les zouzous là !
Damit
On va pas tarder à voir le monstre c'est sûr
Oh p*tain
C'est à l'étage
Allô
* voix incompréhensible *
tg
* Bruits de pas *
Oooooh il y a eu des bruits de paaaaaaas
Damiiit
Faut redescendre. Ok je redescend.
Il y a plus rien en haut
Là il va se passer un truc maintenant
Oh nooon
J'aime pas ça
*toc toc toc*
Oh le bâtard
Oh l'bâtard....Je me casse !!!
Le monstre est là logiquement
Euuuh p*tain attention. Prenez une inspiration..On y va
Oh p*tain il y a le grenier qui s'est ouvert. ok
Reprenez une insp... expirer et reprenez aussitôt une inspiration c'est parti
Ouuuuuffff c'est bon...ah *soulagement*
* musique stressante qui augmente progressivement en intensité *
Ohhh noooooooooon
Elle nous...elle nous...casse le le  corps
c'est fini ?
Ouuuua
personne n'a crié
Mais on ne va pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin
Jeu suivant
Bienvenue sur ce deuxième jeu
Lunacy saint rhodes c'est parti
Je le rappelle on ne doit pas crier ne criez pas
Disclaimer cette vidéo contient des scènes... Voilà
voila elle contient des scène vous êtes avertis
Oh p*tain
Oh p*tain c'est sûr je vais crier
Oh p*tain je vais crier mais plutôt 2 fois qu'une
comme dirais Moricette
Où dois-je allez? je sais même pas ce que je doit faire...Bon on va monter a l'étage c'est ça?
c'est une belle maison
Maison à louer  bien sûr
n'hésitez pas
* bruits de sonnette *
Damit DAMIT j'arrive j'arrive !!
Ça va ça va
ça va ça vaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
J'ai perdu le challenge *rire*
* musique flippante *
*rire*
Eh chérie juste pour te dire je ne rentre pas avant minuit, et en plus tu viens d'apercevoir un inconnu à travers la fenêtre, c'est dommage
S'il te plait laisse les lumières allumées et va dormir aussitôt que tu le peux. Je t'aime. ta maman
Très bien
OOOoooooh oui
Oh p*tain c'est bon je me sens bien
Le téléphone peut être pour appeler la police vu que l'on vient de voir un inconnu
La ligne est coupée ! Excellent
On va monter a l'étage
On va se mettre a l’abri et tout
Une lettre
J'ai trouvé une porte cachée derrière le cabinet dans notre chambre
ah c'est là qu'on doit aller
j'ai trouvé la clef de la porte sur le dessus d'une de nos tasse de thé
P*tain mais mec de devoir chercher des truc comme ça c'est pas trop ma tasse de thé
Donnc heuuuuuuu
* Rugissement *
Mais pourquoi Mais pourquoi déjà je te permet pas pour commencer
Mais qu'est-ce qui t'a pris Mais qu'est-ce qui te prend ?
J'suis là je suis en vidéo tranquillement...mais pourquoi ?!
Mais c'est normal pour toi ça ?!
C'est normal?! je suis outré !! je suis là, je cherche ma tasse de thé comme une vieille merde. P*tain
Où est la clef de la chambre de ta daronne
Déjà il va revenir nous agresser ce p*tain de monstre tu va voir
Mais où est donc la......OHHHHHHH
Mother's bedroom key.YES
Pt'être en haut à droite là...non...
P*tain mais les portraits immenses comme ça mais personne mais PERSONNE au monde n'achète ça
Oh oui !
Allez,  on y va
OK, et là y'a la porte cachée
Mais ouvre-toi !
Est-ce que le monstre n'est pas caché dans ce carton ?
Prank gone wrong, attention on est là !
Y'a une porte cachée ici
DAMIT !!
Une p*tain de porte cachée derrière l'armoire
Mais mec c'est scandaleux ça hein
Allez on y va
On y va qu'est-ce qu'y a dedans
* frôle la crise cardiaque *
Oh p*tain !
Oh mec !
Là j'pense qu'on a perdu ...
un 5e des gens
* Rires *
qui ont crié en voyant ça
Oh m*rde, oh nan ça prend une tournure tellement badante là
Oh naaan
* Coup contre la porte *
oh p*tain
oh nan l'écran qui se retourne, naaan
c'est un gros non
J'peux toujours pas me barrer ?
J'peux toujours pas me barrer
Eh ben on retourne là-bas
Salut
Okay il a disparu on est bien
J'vais être dans une autre dimension ?
OH !
OOH !!
Oh p*tain j'ai encore crié !
mais fait chier, mais le mec il campe derrière la porte !
On se croirait dans Overwatch, là !
Ça ne va pas du t-
Oh p*tain damit
Arrête p*tain d'horloge, arrête
J'reste comme ça en position dans un coin, voilà
accroupi
* Sonnerie du téléphone *
Oh p*tain !
Allô ?
All-
* Personne ne répond *
Mec ta prank a raté, une fois de plus, c'est- vous êtes vraiment pas doués hein
* Ding Dong *
Ooooh
OH, OOH, Ooh, oooohh
Excuse me
I'm so sorry
I have to go upstairs now !
* Bruit du tonnerre *
Damit !
Le mec est juste là !
J'me casse
* Grincements *
Oh oui !
Oui !
Qu'est-ce que j'suis censé fai-
Attends y'a une musique qui s'est- qui s'est jouée (?)
WHOOOH !
P*tain mais-
Désolé mais là jm'y attendais vraiment pas
Je, j'suis désolé
Alors y'a de la musique qui s'est mis ça vient d'où ?
Ça vient de là
Bonjour à tous, p'tit vlog en direct de la maison la plus hantée de France et tout
mon vlog Urbex part en couilles
Aah pt'être faut retourner là, regardez, à mon avis
on va retourner là et la porte au bout sera ouverte, ça va être magnifique c'qui va se passer
regardez bien, attention
Voilà, voilà y'a plus le mannequin
c'est parfait, c'est totalement le chemin
* Ricanements *
What the- mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Whow whow whow, quoi, quoi, quoi, quoi
whow, quoi, quoi, quoi
whow, whow, quoi, quoi, quoi
Nan, nan, nan, nan, NAN !
Excuse-moi !
Elle n'aime pas être dérangée
P*tain !
Mais nan !
Mais nan, faut recommencer du début ?
Mais nan
Mais nan !
Mais nan !!
MAIS NAN !!!
Eh ben j'ai crié, j'ai perdu
Eh ben les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo "Tu cries tu perds challenge"
J'espère que ça vous a plu, si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
Est-ce que vous avez gagné ?
Est-ce que si vous n'avez pas crié vous vous sentez puissant actuellement ?
Bon j'ai perdu, vous êtes plus forts que moi
est-ce que c'est étonnant ?
Non.
* Rire *
J'vous dit à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé les amis
et puis ça m'a fait plaisir de jouer à des petits jeux d'horreur, ça faisait un moment, là, depuis Outlast 2
on a très peu joué à des jeux d'horreur
Voilà, ça fait le cardio, tu vois, c'est comme à la salle, le tapis reuuh qui court (???)
Ça n'a aucun sens.
Merci d'avoir regardé ;)